what does this do you think in La the
cops aren't coming anymore
the police aren't coming yeah they're
considering not sending them to a whole
bunch of cars sounds good
[Laughter]
sounds good Florida
Ronda Sanders
I'm gonna [__] an old woman in Florida
and live with her because this state can
go to hell it is a disgusting it is
snowing and hailing and it is a
nightmare and everybody's like it's a
leg Yeah it's The Vibes in LA City it's
about sex in the last sex baby you gotta
sell a leg and it's hailing and snowing
and a homeless person is smearing their
bloody [__] on the [__] window and it
is a night they are robbing people in
broad daylight here they're hopping in
your car putting a gun in your head and
saying here Florida
I'm going to Florida it is uh it's not
even warm anymore it's not even and
everyone is has Stockholm syndrome
they're like well it's gonna get better
it's gonna get better it's gonna get
better this is like a freak thing it's a
freak thing it's gonna get better
oh of course it'll get better in the
spring that's the whole [__] point
everywhere is nice in the [__] spring
Christ almighty and now they're the cops
aren't even gonna come to and and listen
sometimes that's good because the LAPD
is not exactly the best they're not
exactly always on point but you would
you know if somebody close so what what
what is it here's the list
in its entirety can be found below these
are these are things cops won't come to
now some of them it might make sense
let's see non-criminal and or
non-violent homeless and public quality
of life calls okay so that might be
interesting and non-violent or
non-criminal homeless qualities so like
I have a homeless person in my yard
we don't need to send the cops for that
we you can just reason with the violence
schizophrenic and see what happens
non-criminal mental health calls
makes sense there's a guy on your street
going like this
[Music]
what's the problem with that what's the
problem with that
yeah well like you know some of them
they walk up down the street and they're
literally talking to someone who's not
dead like oh [__]
and you go yeah what's the problem with
that what's the problem with that
send uh sender the a social worker send
somebody there to be like how are you
feeling
um
non-violent calls for service at city
parks sure I don't know what that means
Under the Influence calls alcohol and or
drugs where there is another no crime in
progress so someone who is on out who is
drinking or really drugged up
and you might go hey I'm at the park and
I have my kids here and there's a crazy
homeless man who seems to be on many
many drugs and they go have a nice day
uh non-fatal vehicle accidents
interesting okay
parking violations driveway tow
abandoned vehicles person dumping trash
vicious and Dangerous Dog complaints
where no attack is in progress okay
calls for service for loud noise loud
music or party calls that are Anonymous
or have no victim
landlord tenant disputes loitering
trespassing with no indication of danger
so
let them come in
you let him come
in trespassing with no indication of
jail I just wanted to see Taylor Swift's
yard
just wanted to see it
I got
code 30 alarm response
syringe disposal
that makes sense just hi there's
somebody who keeps throwing syringes in
my shut up
hi someone keeps throwing syringes in my
uh defecating urinating in public look
at 28 28 suspicious
circs possible dead body where no
indication of Foul Play great leave the
body there leave the body there why get
the pigs involved with a dead body
why call the cops over a dead body it's
California the greatest state in the
nation
and this idiot Gavin Newsom really
thinks he's going to run for president
there's like middle-aged [__] boy [__]
believes he's gonna run for president
the state is a laughing stock it's a
national embarrassment and a joke
everyone hates it and I know people like
someone in his orbit that kind of chat
chat a little he thinks he's got like a
shot and brought maybe Elon does too
because that's why Elon moved Tesla back
here so that maybe he thinks within four
to eight years there will be a Newsome
presidency and he can hand them all
those free contracts government
contracts I don't really know but
I mean this is just hilarious most
California voters don't want Newsom to
run for president 70 percent of Voters
don't want to run for president
they should want him to run away
I mean this is like hilarious here a
dead body they may not send police for a
dead body who do you call Uber Eats
I mean who would you call Postman would
again they're gonna send people without
guns or without weapons in our place
okay so Union reps say the establishment
of an unarmed response protocol will
help with the police department's
chronic understaffing problem and allow
police to focus on the actual job of
responding to emergencies
not these things like some drunk
defecating uh person next to a dead body
that's fine
the decision to trim back armed
responses by sworn officers is an
alternative policing approach
that has been deployed in other major
cities to varying levels in the wake of
wide scale civil unrest caused by deadly
police slaying of civilians right so
basically the decision to trim this back
as uh Twitter we decided that it would
make Twitter happy and uh we thought
people were tweeting so this is good in
Virginia armed officers have responded
here's my thing I also don't think that
you need cops in every situation all the
time but there's a lot of [__] things
there that probably could use police
there's a lot of things there where
somebody's heavily intoxicated or being
suspicious something weird something bad
is about to happen something bad may
happen and the idea that you're going to
get rid of any type of police response
and the people are not going to be armed
they're not going to be you're just
going to let things get to a point where
it's going to be very difficult to deal
with them after they've happened
that's what's going to happen when you
when you're basically saying we're going
to ignore something until someone gets
stabbed or someone gets shot or there is
an altercation
it's not good you you don't you know and
I know that everybody's like well
they're just running around the streets
killing people listen there's we got to
get better with the training with cops
you know at least Laurie made it fun see
Lori made it fun Gavin doesn't even make
it fun
Laurie made it fun Laurie met you rooted
for the chaos with Lori right I rooted
for Lori you know I rooted for her she's
a figure that you root for because she
is a a mob boss and now she must take
her place
amongst the shadows in the shadows and
she must launch full-scale attacks like
the Riddler on Gotham City there must be
no [__] let up Lightfoot
you were to continue to raise hell
you were not to fall back
but it's it's just amazing I I just the
idea of like Lori Lightfoot on a lesbian
Cruise playing shuffleboard cheating and
then having someone go what did Lori do
you go she was the mayor of Chicago
she was the criminal mayor of Chicago
the Great American city
um
yeah I mean this is so funny well listen
God bless I mean this is what uh this is
what you get right it's like hey maybe
it'll work maybe it'll work maybe
ignoring the dead bodies will work I
don't know
I mean there's you know you would you
would think that it wouldn't uh be
perfect but you know what do I know
maybe this is not um
maybe this is not uh as bad as it seems
you know this is a
this is a state where people should
experiment I was up in the Pacific
Northwest recently and
the thing about the Pacific Northwest is
that it is uh uh insane
and a lot of the Cities up there you
know again it's just something about the
West Coast there's just something about
the West Coast where people are a bit
off
maybe it's when you leave SoCal you
don't get a lot of vitamin D when you go
up there you get almost no vitamin D
something about the people is a bit off
and uh you know they they kind of like
it they like it the way it is you know
where it's just like endless tent cities
and a lot of mentally unstable people in
the streets and like downtowns being
overrun with chunkies and crime it's
like hey man you know if let's if you're
into it you're into it like that's my
thing it's like if you're into it you're
into it I'm not going to tell you what
to be into it's like you know I'm not
gonna Kink shame you do what you do if
you get off on the idea that there's a
bunch of psychopaths running around in
downtown of your city and you're like a
young professional but it makes you feel
better about yourself which I guess it
does these people they feel better about
themselves they're going and they're
like I believe it's their right to do
whatever they want to do stab me again
uh these people should be able to just
this is what they want these are the
areas they've created they keep voting
for this [__] they keep they want it I
don't know what to say it seems not good
you know when I go and I see all the
crazy people running on the streets and
go that seems unsustainable but then
you'll talk to people and they go well
actually it's much better than it was
you know there's they removed a few of
the tenths and I think that uh we're
heading in the right direction you know
they can't take the people's stuff
though because you see that woman there
I mean that's her thing so the cops
shouldn't be able to move her things and
occasionally she goes nuts and then runs
into traffic but this is her right you
know this is what this is who she is and
why would we like stop her from behaving
that way and you know they're just like
eating like organic food in a place and
then you know as people walk by and as
the end of the world just marches on
outside the end of the world just
marches past people and they just go
well you know I just think that it's
very complicated it's a very strange
situation you're like well maybe you
could just you know bust up these things
and get these people the [__] out of wow
that's actually harder than that because
a lot of people they're trying and it's
very difficult there's a lot of problems
it's very layered I'm like well that
guy's shooting heroin in front of me and
maybe that's less complicated he's
shooting heroin he's using Hera maybe
that's why he's homeless because he's
doing heroin well that's actually the
rents have gone up their rents are
higher I know they are but he's doing
heroin right now and now he's attacking
a woman I know but there's a lot of
protest late stage capital I know that's
not great that's certainly not ideal but
now he's choking that woman to death you
see him choking her to death over there
do you think that requires some
immediate response well there's an
unarmed civilian force that can be
dealing with that and they'll go to
heaven now assess where you know it's
like oh God just let him have it then
[__] let him out I'm I'm sick of
arguing with these [__] people and
that might mean you'll have to live in a
[__] right-wing nightmare where
[__] nobody gets abortions and they
ban anything that's cool and you're just
you know you're living in the [__]
like like some weird theocracy I don't
know
but I mean uh you know it's just uh it's
getting silly it's getting silly in this
place and I don't know what to tell
people other than just [__] like I
don't know folks figure it out